about are you bald do you have hair why
is this around your head why do you wear
skirts why are you covered up
disrespectful things like that and
that's not okay that first of all does
not concern them on what we wear then if
they have questions they should at least
ask for some more respectful err and not
to be rude about it in me appleís there
was no racism at all I had all friends
that were all different
white black Mexican when I came to st.
cloud I have never felt like this in my
whole life like they are so rude and
disrespectful to Somalis I all my
friends used to be all white all white
and when I came here I have no white
friends are all Somali the Minneapolis
community they accept everything because
it's a big city they accept everything
there yes all diverse and here when they
see Somali they'll like talk about them
like we know English we know what you're
saying you know us as Somali students
we've all encountered some sort of
racist act you know a we're fed up with
a the white students who are racist
never actually talked to us Somali
student if they did I thought they will
get to know us much better and
appreciate
smelly I'm the lucky ting the piece
welcome to the show the D show I'm with
Sheikh Muhammad Hassan peace Beauty
Islamic Salaam on telework at ask Muslim
calm you're involved with this beautiful
organization and the work that you guys
are doing is wonderful people have so
many queries so many questions and they
can come to a Muslim who's out there
qualified as you guys to answer many of
these questions how long you been
involved with this project I was not a
matter Heyman abdullah saleh mozzarella
how bad nice being with you like a la
heron for coming
I've been with ask a Muslim for almost
two years now hamdulillah and we are
just working with the Dawa and
facilitating the Dawa to those who need
to tell what's the most important things
that you see now like you're originally
from where Somalia I'm from Somalia are
you related to Sheikh Saeed from my
workers your mustard here is Abu Huraira
I think he was over there Abu Huraira
you know Sheikh side you play ball with
him now I know him I know she'll say
Allah Heron is turning the Masjid of our
era used to be now he's running Sakina
another center so we came from Somalia
both of us
and he came from North Side and I came
from the south side but there is not
another relationship you when you play
ball you're on opposite teams
the same team how about you know Imam
for me you know Sheikh face so from
Chicago Imam face well I know I shall
say vessel and when we was in the BG
calm he was dead also and keep Iman
faithful now it was there silver so now
I also went to school with his brother
Abdul Latif
we were in same class his older brother
so I know him
Jacque ilaha illaallah house Faisal
Salam alikoum I want to love work at
what advice now do you have for the
amounts or the people out there you know
to be able to make that human connection
and what are the what are the things
that are needed now because you can
bring some of this back home culture
here doesn't
with the culture here so that you don't
again there are things that are fixed in
the Dean you can't compromise them you
found me but that you've seen with your
experience that people need to be
equipped to be able to answer some of
these tough questions um that WA has a
principalis and no one can just give a
fatwa no one can just answer the
questions but you have to have a
knowledge you have to have knowledge
because what is saying a ghost bag that
you are like you are saying oh Allah say
this are also like a salami this say in
this so you have to have the knowledge
when you're saying and it's not going to
be an F to only know the hadith and the
ayah coding hadith and ayah but
sometimes you have to know the filth and
you have to know also something called a
middle one al which mean is that the
flat wall at the end the the part is
that the religion also sometimes you
know goes and was the halal was you know
the the the call of Fiat and also you
have to know also you have to equip
yourself knowledge there and knowing
that also the Bible and sometimes you
know it's very tough questions and if
you don't know all this thing and you're
trying to help this person
it is good always to say that I don't
know that's also how that they'll have
you had any experience with the media
people asking you as an imam saying what
are you doing to combat any extremism
you have you know in Somalia they have
what is this Boko Haram and what and
people's minds are confused they think
Islam anyone was Muslim practicing he's
a radical how do you deal with it now
and we have that all the time
misconceptions and also we answer what
what we know what we don't know we don't
know it but Islam is always clear you
know nice and what a last panel what
Allah said in the book is clear if
anyone is following what a sorcerer
Salim has mentioned it is clear also and
the way the Muslim is enacting then when
the cut when the media approaches us and
asked us or questions which are
sometimes very complicated you know they
are just fishing little awkward word
that you said but it is better you know
to clear
the answer whatever you know what do you
don't know that means you don't know it
yeah what do you say in this case when
they try to instantiate it when they try
to put Islam next to terrorism right
Abdullah Islam is not terrorizing
anybody and Islam is the is the mercy
that Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala sent to
the mankind when prophet mohammed was
sent to the people last potala state he
was send to the mankind so Islam is just
the way of life
Islam is a piece is LOM comes all the
package that the human needs so when you
only see that there are you know
somebody who did some extreme thing did
it
we cannot attach it that one into the
Islam it's like the way this is what
they say sometimes I had that a very
nice analogy which is that if you drive
a nice car you know if that car you know
it is accident so is the car it is the
reason there are responsibilities the
car or the driver
the fault is a driver so those who are
just you know acting and claiming that
there are Muslims if they do something
that which out of Islam that means we
cannot attach that action into the
Islamic Islam is a beautiful religion
Islam is the religion of the Minecon
mine kind and you will receive by blacks
in Islam and believe in it a peace and
prosperity beautiful what other advice
do you have for those who are really
motivated I mean this is a
responsibility to share this message
with love with understanding with
kindness and many people they're not
heating the car they're not realizing
that this is indeed a responsibility and
every Muslim to his or her capability is
that correct now every Muslim is
ambassador to represent this beautiful
religion and some of the scholars they
are coding in their books saying that
when Islam reaches into Indonesia I'm
some motherf R is the country's which
now a lot of Muslims are practicing
Islam
so Islam never went there by force but
it went by those who are Muslims those
who are representing Islam the way it is
those who are carrying the message of
Islam and then when they went there
people see it and then by seeing them
and the way they are behaving and
they're you know good manners they
become a Muslims so each and every one
who is a Muslim especially those who are
in the Western countries they need to
represent Islam as it is when allah
subhanho wa taala feel it into prophet
muhammad and also a problem Hamid is
saying that believe and evil oh I just
reach those who are non-muslims give the
Dawa even one verse so that we have to
equip ourselves by the proper etiquette
the proper knowledge and a good
representing Islam and become
ambassadors of Islam so that we can
share our neighbors we can share our
co-workers we can share our classmates
into the beautiful religion of Islam I'm
here with the brothers here in Columbus
Ohio ask a Muslim if you have any fears
apprehensions anything you want to know
about Islam ask a Muslim and get those
things cleared up in your mind and we'll
see you next time until then peace be
with you Islamic